um one of the things that you guys did
very very well was you kind of continued
to
uh reinvent uh what was on the menu and
kind of innovate
and keep pushing forward in terms of the
offerings that you had
uh there's things like the munchkins or
the culadas and all kind of all this
stuff talk a little bit about just what
was the
process internally how intentional is it
versus kind of serendipitous
uh in terms of creating these new
products and really
scaling them to a national organization
uh so that you can
remain fresh and kind of at the top of
mind for consumers
early on it was serendipitous the
introduction of jumbo java which
from a six ounce to go cup of coffee to
a 10 ounce cup of coffee
came from a competitor or a marketing
head i hired from a competitor
munchkins was an idea that surfaced from
our
hartford franchise on this a lady by the
name of edna demery the wife of our
franchise owner bob damery
she created munchkins but later on it
became very sophisticated and very
process oriented
basically we had a first-rate marketing
department
we had product managers for bakery
beverage
and donut categories their job was to
continually
search the marketplace the competition
the consumer
we took ideas every which way we ballot
tested them
we tested them thoroughly a year in
advance in order to ensure that they
delivered on the
same store sales growth that we wanted
we try news is important in a retail
business
whether it be price product promotion
there always should be some activity
that excites and enthralls the consumer
given another reason
to come into the store and so we manage
those calendars very carefully
and product was among them and and in
terms of business strategy
we used a planning model it's now pretty
much commonplace when we started
we we modeled our performance way back
when we first ran into trouble
so in the early 70s we were using jay
forester's concept of modeling
and we wanted to grow earnings at at
least 15 that stroke
that drove us to keep innovating and
adjusting
and need to plant saplings well in
advance
of the time that you might need those
earnings and those that worked out well
you know we'd water them and make sure
that they grew and those that didn't
work out so well we'd stop
so there would be a lot of a lot of
false starts
you got to sort of put a lot to catch
fish you got to put a lot of hooks in
the water
sometimes so we did we did a lot of uh
measured experimentation still achieving
our objective but with an eye to the
future
both in terms of markets and in terms of
products and in terms of business
strategy
absolutely you also uh in multiple
other organizations you're involved in
these either as the operator or
on the board they've built very
recognizable defendable brands
and so obviously um there's some value
to that
talk about how important that was how
intentional the brand building
and kind of how you saw that as an asset
as you built these businesses
i think brand is hugely important to me
a brand is a shorthand for the
goods and services on offer and
for the consumer it basically is a time
saver
their most precious asset is time
and it allows someone when you have a
well-identified
brand that consistently delivers it
shorthands and saves the consumer time
that is a valuable benefit to the
consumer
and so for example when we were building
our chain out
we did not go where we got an interest
from a prospective franchisee to grow in
china and wyoming
we were very intentional in terms of
building distribution in a market
to build brand we weren't so aware of
its value until we actually bought the
mr donut chain and rebadged it
then we were among very few who were in
a position to really measure
brands so in new england where the
duncan brand was much stronger than the
mr brand
same store same operator a minor
remodeling a change from the mr sign
to the duncan sign sales went up 40
let me repeat that 40 value of a brand
in markets where we had similar
distribution some places in pennsylvania
sales went up 12 in those markets where
duncan had no presence
no history no brand recognition and mr
had something like toronto they had 10
or 15 stores
we had none when we rebadged one in the
first and second so
sales went down 10 so i could say in our
case
if you want to know what the value of a
brand was in those days if the
average sales of the store was were five
or six hundred thousand dollars and now
close to a million but but maybe even
more um but but you know a value of a
brand
can be worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars to a store
and what's interesting about that is
um why do you why do you think that is
it because there's a trust with the
brand
and especially in kind of the food
services uh retail chain business
they kind of know what they're going to
get when they walk in and so there's
this promise of consistency and
and kind of value or is it something
else as to why the brand was so powerful
when you would go into markets
trust is important in every relationship
it's essential
and no successful relationship exists
without trust and if you look behind it
when you don't have trust
it's rare you can ever have any kind of
success and so
you know trust is the ability basically
in my in my view
of four things it's it's sincerity your
public and private conversation the same
competence you basically can live up to
the standards that you set up
uh reliability as you meet your promises
and finally is care
so i think the answer to your question
is people have trust and
the fast food business qsr business
quick service restaurant business
uh runs on two things always has it
seems to continue to this day
and it really runs on value and
convenience and value is more than price
value is a whole series of attributes
one of which
is trust i think i place a high value on
trust